hello everyone a very warm good morning
we'll be starting in two more minutes
and mean by We Begin it would be great
if you could introduce yourself in the
chat box and let us know about your
educational background and your research
interests as well
good morning Dr pankaj
hello good morning everybody I hope I'm
Audible
yes you are audible to us we can also
see you thank you for joining us
great
all right I think we are good to begin
and to start the recording a very warm
good
a very warm good morning to one and all
present here I would like to first of
all introduce you all to the Siamese
club and our vision and then I would
pass on to Dr pankaj for his talk today
so psyomix is an initiative taken by the
students associated with pine biotech
the goal of the club is to help students
learn about bioinformatics research via
group sessions easy to take courses
debates and discussions the psyomix club
aims at encouraging young minds to push
their critical thinking limits beyond
the school and college curriculum to
promote inquisitiveness and inculcate
principles of Applied learning among the
students the focus of the club is to
debate and discuss ideas and build up
the spirit of scientific inquiry among
the members
we are excited to start the four psionic
session for the fall 2022 and the theme
of the session revolves around
multi-omics data analysis and
bioinformatics the psionic sessions are
aimed at bringing together the network
of experts Educators and students from
all around the world to learn from each
other interact and discuss advances in
the field
discussions will highlight challenges
involved in research using computational
tools for Big Data opportunities in this
outgrowing field and applications
here are the links to join the scionics
club by joining the student Club you
will broaden your horizons and get an
opportunity to explore collaborative
projects internships and careers learn
from experts through virtual sessions
and find mentors you will also get to
explore online platforms designed to
help find Opportunities acquire new
skills and find opportunities for
yourself
you all must be curious to know how can
you get noticed in the community what
are the challenges
opportunities and where is
bioinformatics headed the answer to all
the above queries is to learn about the
critical skills needed in academic and
Industry positions see what others are
doing hear from the leaders in Project
driven education that have demonstrable
outcomes in learning and placement and
learn about the future of data science
and biology in research and applications
in agriculture medicine and
biotechnology
our main focus lies in clearing concepts
of bioinformatics and related feeds like
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
and data science Insight on how to use
bioinformatics tools biologists can
learn how to apply bioinformatics in
real life applications
brainstorming sessions would help
biologists to enhance their critical
thinking abilities application of coding
platform in bioinformatics and gaining
experience in computational biology and
data science skills
please follow the steps that I would
just tell to register yourself on the
omics logic loan portal you need to
create your profile on the omics logic
learn portal that is free of course to
leverage the resources that I just
mentioned about and after setting up an
account it would be great if you could
update your profile which includes your
first and last name a profile picture
connected social media accounts and a
brief biography about yourself and your
educational background in that way we
could feature your progress on our
social media handles and highlight some
of your achievements
self-learning of the introductory
coursework related to bioinformatics
Comic studies like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and space omics and data science that
includes bioinformatics using R and
python after successfully signing up on
the portal you can go to the courses
section where we have listed two free
courses introduction to bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules which gives you
a glimpse of terminologies and
Healthcare applications in
bioinformatics and multiomics Fields
one of the aims of the cyanics class is
to guide the students on the common
queries that they face while kicking
while kickstarting their career through
group discussions such as review report
writing based on the self-assessed
courses debate on the brainstorming
areas in bioinformatics and data science
presentations on the research papers
discussions and exchange of ideas for
research project development how is
bioinformatics industry different from
Academia how can students transition
from Academia to Industry we also
discuss about job and internship
opportunities for undergraduate and
postgraduate students building soft and
technical skills and great and provide
guidance interview or CV
so what will you learn today
availability of Big Data not only opens
up unprecedented opportunities of
zooming into a biological system but
also raises new challenges for data
mining and Analysis the wave of new
technologies has opened up the
opportunity for cost effective High
throughput profiles of biological
systems generating tons of biological
data Big Data era is creating a pressing
need to bridge the gap between the high
throughput technological development and
our ability for managing analyzing and
integrating the biological Big Data now
let's start this session without further
Ado I would like to invite Dr pankaj
yadav Dr yadav has a background in
biostatistics genetics and
bioinformatics at present he works as an
assistant professor at Indian Institute
of Technology jodhpur India previously
he has worked as senior data scientist
at Reliance Geo infocom Limited in
Hyderabad India as a research scientist
at corteva Agri science Hyderabad
scientists at German Center Research
Center Heidelberg Germany scientists at
University of Keene Germany and research
assistant at helmholz research and
Germany's Germany Dr yada has a rich
experience in statistical method
development for Gene environment
interaction studies at dkf said he
worked on drawing statistical inferences
on multiple myeloma cancer data sets
obtained from various hospitals in
Germany and UK at the helmho center he
worked on developing machine learning
algorithm for quantitative structure
activity relationship analysis his work
has been published in peer-reviewed
journals he has contributed to several
International conferences seminars and
workshops he received the inspired
faculty award in 2018 from Indian
National Science Academy
we are pleased to have you Among Us Dr
pankaj I would like to now hand over the
stage to you
okay thank you so much for kind
invitation and kind in introducing me
uh let me once again uh say good morning
to all the participants who are here who
have joined the session
so let me share my screen
come on
are my slides visible can you please
confirm
no sir I can't see your slides
foreign
it says one participant can share at a
time
so can you try now I haven't stopped
sharing maybe this would help
I work now
foreign
can you help us with that
uh shall I think Dr pankaj the host
maybe that works
instead of media the host can you please
try now
okay let's try it
foreign
[Music]
again
um
yeah please take the host permissions
back and then you can join by uh who
wants to drive it
okay
so can you try to log in again yeah
yeah
okay
I think it's some issue with my knife
foreign
it would be great to hear from
participants about their backgrounds we
would like to know you all come from
which
Fields by technology bioinformatics or a
different field than that and are you a
researcher or a student
good morning Dr whipping
I guess sir has joined back can you make
a post
yes I can see so
foreign
is it visible now
um so while sharing the screen if you
select which screen you want to share
you have to click on OK after that
I have share the entire screen I don't
know why it's okay
let me
yeah now we can yes now we can see
you can admit yourself
um so we can't tell you why I think you
need to unmute yourself hello
okay so let me then start again so uh
today we are going to learn about Big
Data uh in biology and what are its
future perspectives
um my goal is to um
expose the Young Generation who is here
to uh what opportunities this field has
and what are the challenges that we face
uh so um many of you may be new in this
field
and uh some definitions that you will
encounter most of the time
is
um are listed here just very quickly I
want to take it for those definitions
so first of all uh what is data
so um data is a set of values of
qualitative or quantitative variables
about one or more persons or it can be
or some objects right so some can say
the height of some set of individuals
that is also one set of values of height
measured in some units and that makes
you data
and what is data set it's a collection
of related set of information composed
of separate elements that can be
manipulated computationally as a unit
so you have more than one uh variables
that you have stored in the data set
then what is database or data
repositories that we usually find a lot
of repositories online nowadays
so it's basically virtual data storage
that stores organizes validates and
makes accessible the core data related
to a particular system of systems right
it can be any biological system or it
can be an
um communication system or it can be any
kind of defined system
uh like protein databases or
the nucleotide sequence databases these
are all
examples of databases uh metadata uh
usually you also see this kind of
information like metadata so what what
it is what is metadata so it's actually
the data that describes our data that we
are looking at
for example if you look at the PubMed
you have this titles abstracts author
names keywords
Etc these are all the metadata that
describes the publication
now
um we also see a lot of workflows that
exist now we as bioinformaticians will
develop also a lot of workflows
which actually are a defined series of
tasks for processing the data
and um
now uh a lot of people also hear about
data science uh which actually in true
sense is an interdisciplinary field in
which quantitative and analytical
approaches as well as the process and
systems are developed which are then
used to extract the knowledge and
insights from increasingly large and
complex data
then we also hear a lot about deep
learning which is basically the type of
network in which each successive layers
so it's kind of some architectures uses
output from some previous layer uh as an
input and it is very similar to our
communication patterns in our biological
nervous systems where a lot of neurons
the transfer information from one layer
to another layer
then in omics which is multi-omics uh
usually we call
um is actually a collective
characterization and made
measurement of full of biological
molecules that translates into the
structure function and dynamics of an
organism or organisms
we will talk about sorry examples of
this like genomics proteomics
metabolomics Etc
now if you can recall
um all these uh use amount of layers of
information that biology has it starts
it can be actually looked from the
perspective central dogma
uh where we start with the genome where
usually we have the DNA or the genes as
the inflammatory in elements then from
genomes we get the transcriptome level
data's primarily comprises of mRNA then
uh proteom which comprises of the
proteins their structure sequences Etc
and then metabolome which is comprising
of information about the metabolites of
uh of an of an individual
so
um genome is what can happen actually
and transcriptome is what appears to be
happening and proteome in some sense
what makes it happen and what has
happened and is happening is trans is
encoded into the metabolism
so this is uh omics Cascade in in in
short view
um
so um so we have a lot of data that we
generate in biology and in this slide I
will try to uh show you that how uh
biology or is nowadays not a single
individual's expertise but it involves a
lot of expertise different domains it's
truly multi-disciplinary uh domain in
order to solve our research problems
so if we start here
um with the mice with the experimental
metadata to say uh we have the mice we
collect the samples from the mice and
then we transform it into the batteries
or some do some kind of experiment like
it can be the blood cells
um then uh here a set of different
expertise is involved you need to have
some expertise in clinical uh biology or
you need to have have to have
experimental uh techniques know how
about how you perform this kind of
things
then uh we have uh next layer of
information that is generated by uh the
machines that are all called sequencing
machines Etc or microarrays
that ultimately generates uh this kind
of information which is an image
so here another set of expertise is
involved so one has to have an
understanding of how these machines or
equipments actually works and what kind
of uh what kind of equipment is suitable
for what kind of problem
uh here once you have the image data
that is being generated by the machine
now the next goal is basically now you
are in the analytical domain so you need
to have an an expertise now in uh in the
buy-informatics or you can say the data
analytics
where you have to make sense of this
data that has been generated uh as an
image so image is basically uh
transformed into our text uh data so it
again some algorithms are used to
transform this
and then we need to have some sort of
analytical skills to make sense from
this textual data a text format data it
can be Excel CSV or whatever format how
we can generate the knowledge out of
this data and interpretation and data
knowledge again it requires the
expertise from different individuals
so you can see this uh slide actually
show a very small example of how one
experiment has been can be done and then
how the technique technology is used to
generate the data and then how data
analytics is performed and then how you
make the inference of biological system
so uh this is very uh true or typical to
many of the problems that we solve in
different results labs
um I mean this is just to show you
different experimental platforms whether
it is the NGS sequences Next Generation
sequences or metabolic profiling that is
from NMR or fmatrix transcriptome
LS lcms
proteomics
Etc
foreign
biological data types then we have
primarily the genomics transcriptomics
proteomics metabolomics microbiomics
Imaging Etc we can have a lot of lot of
data and different types of data we can
obtain in biological experiments
I will show you some examples of how
these different types of data are useful
and where are their applications what
actually are these data types
uh so if you look at genomics it's
basically uh either the nucleotide
sequences that we get from uh sequencers
or we usually get also the genotypes
which tell you uh the variant
information
so the
product the product of applications we
all we usually have for this kind of
data is is in gene finding either we are
using this kind of data for Gene finding
or we are doing the functional
annotation or or we are doing the
sequence alignment or we are performing
the comparative analysis
oh we are performing the phylogenetic
inferences and also associations
analysis like genome-wide Association
analysis
um kind of technology that that is used
here is primarily the Next Generation
sequencing nowadays
to generate this genomics data
uh now if we look at the transcriptomics
data
so we have RNA expression levels then we
have transcription Factor bindings then
chromate instruction information these
are kind of data that we encounter as
transcriptome
and the application wise we have a lot
of applications of transcriptomic data
so it includes differential expression
analysis to identify which genes are
expressed in which conditions that kind
of analysis usually perform so for
example how how which genes
are expressing a situation uh as
compared to healthy individuals so um
then one can also perform the functional
enrichment analysis to identify which
kind of path phase are enriched uh then
one can also perform transcriptional
regulation or also called the causal
reasoning
and there are several other applications
of this kind of data that we get then uh
from Technologies point of view we have
uh microarrays that are used to generate
uh uh the transcriptom data or nowadays
we also have the Next Generation
sequencing approaches to generate
transcriptomics data
uh the third uh major type of data that
we encounter in in multi-omics
categories is the proteomics and here we
usually get the information about
proteins levels or a protein structures
like 3D structures or protein protein
interactions these are kind of data that
nowadays we generate
uh
what what are the applications so there
are several applications again so we can
[Music]
do a protein identification kind of
analysis or we can do functional
predictions of a given protein we can
also do some structural predictions for
a given uh sequence of protein
or we can perform a
structural comparisons to compare
different structures
or we can do a molecular Dynamic
simulation kind of analysis to identify
or simulate the system how would the
system behave or how would a protein
protein complex would uh would be
interacting
uh so from Technologies point of view
the there are several techniques like
gel electrophoresis mass spectrometry
protein arrays and several others that
are used to generate this kind of data
now uh if we look at the fourth category
of the data that is metabolomics uh it
has also a huge potential and in and
also lot of research work is going on in
this domain as well uh the data
comprises mainly of metabolites or small
molecules levels that are present in the
system
one can perform
um from this data pathway or network
analysis to identify the the kind of
metabolites that are involved in in a
disease condition
uh the technologies that are often used
here is the chromatography uh NMR or
Mass spectrometry to generate metabolome
data
now um
if the slide actually give you
um
just an overview of several things that
that are involved here so um here uh if
you look we start with the different
categories of the multi-ohmics data so
uh like genomics and transcriptomics
proteomics metabolomics and
um also nowadays clinical and amazing
data sets
uh and several other kind of warmings
like a microbiomex glycomics etc
um one can use uh machine learning
approaches or statistical approaches to
uh integrate these different layers of
the data so the idea is to integrate
this data sets so that we can bring the
information from one layer to another
layer and actually look across the
layers not just looking at a single uh
type of data here but looking across the
layer of the data
our goal is again uh to predict uh
whether we are expecting health and
disease condition based on these all
data that we are available with or we
can do the biomarker discovery or we can
do models and prediction Etc
so we the idea here is that one has to
we now look at holistically rather than
just uh not uh narrow-minded thing of
looking at just what one category of the
data
uh now if you look at uh the amount of
data that has been generated uh over the
years so if you look at the ncbi
database so you can see there is an
exponential increment in the number of
sequences that are available in in ncbi
uh now uh
if you look at the number of uh users
also so in the red line is the number of
users that has also actually increased
that actually tells you the number of
jobs that are available or the number of
jobs that have been created in this
field
so there is a huge uh potential and this
numbers are actually growing and growing
in the coming years
um the amount of data that is being
generated is really huge and uh in
biology and it is uh if there is no
actually there is a lot of worry also to
how to handle this and how to store and
organize this um lose amount of data
that is being generated every day in the
biology
uh so this is just to show you a scale
of uh how the computer stores the data
ranging from the smallest unit of byte
to the
extreme is Leota byte
um this slide show you the the data
repositories that we often use and has a
lot of data that that we have that I
have mentioned in previous slides so for
example a tcga has a lot of data related
to cancer
and uh you will find a lot of uh
different types of multi-ohomics data
that is available like RNs DNA SEC
snv DNA methylation and several other
kinds of data then uh another uh
data is CP Tech
which also stores the cancer data
proteomics mainly storing the proteomics
data
uh then uh Target is another data set
which provides mainly for the Pediatric
cancers
uh the gene expression M iron expression
Etc
then uh omics Discovery index is a very
good platform where you will find a
Consolidated data sets from different
repositories that has been created for
uniform framework
you will find a lot of genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics data on this uh in in this
platform or mix a discovery index
um
this is just a snap shot from this data
repository economics Discovery index or
Odis and you can see that there are
several uh ways you can extract the data
so you can see the most access data set
or latest data sets Etc that have been
recently added it also visualizes how
the the different data sets are
increasing uh is growing with the year
and one can also search by organ
different organs and Etc or different
cancer types so there is a lot of data
that is available and one can access it
on this platform
another platform that I mentioned is the
tcga so tcga as you can see uh again
this is the snapshot from this website
uh so all the next dozen of years tcga
are generated over 2.5 petabytes of
genomic epigenomic transcriptomic and
proteomic data and the data which has
already led to improvements in our
ability to diagnose treat and prevent
different kinds of cancer and this is a
good thing is that it is publicly
available for anyone who is in the
research Community one can use it
download it one can perform the analysis
so this is a very nice uh useful
platform
another platform that I want to
show you is the human cell Atlas uh
which stores the data from Individual
cells multiomics data from Individual
cells so the goal of this was to map the
human body at the cellular level and
this community has actually generated a
huge amount of data multi-oh mixed data
again this is also an Open Access by
some standardized pipelines uh this
slide May a little bit outdated but you
can still see that there is huge amount
of data like summarize here 4.5 million
cells from 33 organs and there are 289
donors and more than 30 projects in
different labs are running uh for user
utilizing this data from this portal so
this is also a very useful platform to
access big data and multi-ohomics data
there are several other as well but I
just want to show you on this these
three highlights uh now uh next why we
want to actually integrate the omics
data why we cannot but we have not
learned from the individual data types
uh and how it can help and why we
integrate the data so
um so far uh we have been looking uh at
the individual data some Labs were
looking only at the genomics and Labs
were looking at the proteomics and Etc
um so this cartoon actually show you uh
the blind man and the elephant story
where uh
the one if you just touch the tail you
cannot actually uh guess what what
whether it is elephant or something else
so what we can learn from an experiment
may depend on where we look and how we
look and the scope of our view uh and
the idea of the integration is that we
look rather we should have actually a
holistic view rather than a reductionist
view
uh if we have different layers of data
like genome transcriptom proteom
metabolome Etc so we um uh we look so
the traditionally people has been
looking at these single omics now um we
are looking at the transforming which is
more of a holistic View
which can provide actually a lot of
information that one can miss in this
singles or mix or conventional
approaches that which were rather
reductionist
um I will not go into much details of
mathematics or the approaches that are
used but just want to show you that uh
there are different ways also in which
you can actually perform the integration
of these different types of data in
multiomics
so uh these are categorized into two
types one is the horizontal integration
schemes scheme where you integrate
actually one kind of uh one kind of data
from uh different uh samples so here
let's say if you have mRNA data uh from
different samples different studies
different Research Laboratories you can
how you can combine or integrate that
information just like we perform the
meta-analysis
um another approach is the vertical
integration which can be performed into
two ways mainly so parallel integration
which is shown here on the left side and
the bottom where we one is one can
perform a parallel integration of all
different different kinds of omics
modalities
and uh second type of uh vertical
integration is called hierarchical
integration one can perform a
hierarchical integration of different uh
different modalities of omics by in a
hierarchical manner
um these are some tools and methods that
that are listed here if you are
interested you can look a little bit
more details about these methods you can
see there are the list of methods that
are available
uh for integrating this kind of
multi-omix data are really huge list uh
it depends what kind of approaches that
has been used and what are the uh
methods that are available so for
example for the Bayesian methods they're
the most commonly used is the mofa MFA
uh and I cluster plus is also used and
for network based approach if you want
to use is the net ICS
um and then for multivarite multivariate
analysis we have mix omics that is an r
package I will show you in a couple of
minutes
um
and you can also see that these are
categorized and colored by different
digits of typing and this is insights
and biomarker prediction etcetera what
kind of use your applic utility based
tools have
um so this is just one example how you
can understand the integration so if you
start with some experiment uh here shown
in the in the middle uh you can start in
two different directions you can in from
the same set of samples you want you can
extract perform the lipin extraction uh
then you perform the lipid extract and
then you perform the MS analysis
eventually and then you get the after
the data analysis you can get you can
identify uh and quantify let's say some
lipid species on the right cycle uh if
side of this slide you can if you start
with the same set of samples and perform
the East lysine protein digestion you
prepare the peptide mixture and then you
again perform the MS analysis that can
give you uh identify and quantification
of different set of proteins now since
this these two types of analysis that
has been performed how you actually
infer uh the NR or how you can integrate
these two different set of informations
that is actually will be very
informative
all right
so the data integration from analytical
point of view
if you look uh as I said so there are
several ways so you can either perform a
matrix factorization Bayesian approach
or natural based or multiple steps
Etc
uh here again the idea is that you look
across the different data layers in
order to infer or to correlate make is
inference across the different layers
not looking only at the single layer but
across the different layers
um so how so what do we expect from such
kind of omics data Integrations so we
expect an overview of the role of each
omics in a biological system a better
understanding of the relationship
between the omics types uh we expect a
molecule signature with insights into
molecular mechanisms
and a predictive analytical model that
can be generated the help of this kind
of integration approach and possibly all
of the Abu that that are shown here in
order to get the integration outcome
uh so here our focus is that we want to
integrate and reduce the dimensions of
the omics data in a multivariate fashion
and identify the molecular signatures of
a particular disease or condition
uh I was saying that uh there is an r
package that that is quite useful
so this is mixomics
uh and here an R toolkit for
multivariate data analysis and
statistical integration of biological
omics data so it is quite a useful
friendly and easy to use tool if you
want to perform multiomics Integrations
I would suggest this tool
uh this is actually the way this method
works so it has two types of possible
Integrations one is the n integration
and P integration so in the N
integration it's basically the data sets
are measured on the same n samples but
from different omics
uh whereas in case of P integration data
sets are measured on the same key
features but from Independence studies
so you have this this the kind of data
that you have is uh is different
and there are some challenges as well so
here for example usually we encounter
that small and and big big p so we have
the same small number of individuals who
has the data but a lot of features that
we get
um
then the next uh boom that we have seen
in few years is the single cell
multiomics data so here uh rather than
the bulk looking at the bulk tissue or
bulk sample from to generate the
multi-omics but rather we are looking
here at the single cell and
omics data is generated from a single
cells that's why it's called single cell
warmings and it is you can imagine that
huge if you have millions or billions of
cells and you have the omics modalities
different modalities being generated
from it is each individual cells how
much data uh you can generate
so this slide just show you an overview
of different uh uh steps or analytical
workflow that that one one has to
perform or one can perform with the
single cell multiomics data sets uh
ranging from uh the trajectory in France
or differential expression you can
perform compositional analysis or you
can identify the meta stable States Etc
another uh
another uh
kind of uh in future or you can say a
lot of huge work that has been expected
in the future is the
um how we can store the Digital Data
into into DNA and I will show you I will
first tell you why is it required
so a lot of data as I said is being
generated and I'm trying to show you in
the previous slides that the data that
is being generated is huge and a lot how
we will run out of the storage
capacities in in coming years and to
store that much amount of data so how we
can actually
efficiently store this data huge amount
of data that is being produced in the
biology uh that is the challenge here
um so Digital Data basically describes
electronic Technologies so we have I
will not talk about different other
kinds of data that is being generated so
primarily the image data so how do we
actually store those kind of data so
digitally uh digital describes actual
electronic technology that generates
thoughts and processes data in terms of
two states positive and non-positive
um
so here the very fundamental uh
principle has been shown so somebody
sends a signal it is being its Digital
Data of course that is being encoded
um so that no it cannot be read by
easily by any third party so then it is
decoded and then it is sent to receiver
so you get the data protection right so
your data is protecting
um so um there is a huge Challenge and
also future towards storing this kind of
digital image data Text data or some
kind of other image data that that is
being generated into DNA so how can we
when we can store this as a DNA so this
slide actually show you the workflow of
how we can store this any kind of
textual or
or any kind of image data so one has to
first uh generate or generate the coding
for the corresponding uh zero data and
then one can synthesize the DNA and then
one can store it
and that is the one and step one two and
three
so here y one has to uh why this is
actually beneficial what is the
motivation here is that because DNA is
as you can say it's very Compact and a
huge amount of information
can be stored very easily in a compact
way it's like this kind of test tubes
so um if one has to retrieve this that
is step four so one can get it from the
storage and then one can perform the
sequencing given that nowadays the cost
of sequencing is declining in the future
it is also well supposed to decline a
bit further this is what is expected and
then one can decode using the some kind
of decoder in order to retrieve the
original information that we started
with at step one
right so one can store a huge amount of
amazing image data or text data in into
DNA using this workflow it is very
important given that the amount of data
that is being produced is used and we
will run out of storage memories in
coming years
okay so I think
that is more or less so take home
message so we are entering a new era
that first requires a data driven
approaches to make sense of the
biological data and from a holistic uh
to a hypothesis generating approach
and it does not exclude prior biological
knowledge such as pathway analysis in
computational methods
new fields are emerging that blends
computationally Savvy biological
scientists and vice versa
and we are the we are focusing more now
or we should focus more towards
development of computational tools which
is very important to advance our
knowledge by utilizing the biological
data
um so with this I would like to thank
you so this uh figure actually show you
the uh the each cell the cell cell
network so you can see how complex it is
um this is again showing you the huge
capacity of the biological data
complexity of the biological data okay
thank you so now please let me know if
there are any questions
thank you so much so
foreigners and also the other biologists
we have amongst us today
uh thank you so much
participants if you have any questions
okay please put in the chat box you can
also note yourself if you wish to and
ask your question from Dr pankaj
hello
yes hi smoothie
yeah hi uh good afternoon sir sir
actually I did my dissertation in
systems biology during my Master's in
biomedical Sciences from Delhi
University it completed this year only
and I do want to uh explore the system
biology and other bioinformatics tools
uh more and so I'm trying to get some
kind of presentations to have a basic
and ground level understanding like
yours but sir I just wanted to ask about
the topological analysis which you would
do or which one would do after the
network construction so can you please
brief me about that topological analysis
how how we can do it and what are the
tools to get it done
foreign
though in this session uh but you can
use cytosuke there is one tool that is
called cytosuke
and you can perform a lot of lot of
topological analytics like you can
calculate different kinds of
um uh
you can say the majors like
um
centrality yes exactly centrality or in
between a centrality there are several
kind of measures that are used to
um to infer that the topology of the
network and one can easily perform even
if you don't have that kind of coding
skills you can use cytoscope which is a
very user-friendly Tool uh to calculate
different features it's just on some you
need to import your network in the there
and then you can there are options to
calculate what whatever kind of
topological measures that you want to
calculate
so I am just typing the link of the
cytoscope in the chat box
give me a second
okay
so you can download the cytosuke and use
that for calculating the different
topological measures
yeah thank you so much sir so another
talk was that how much is the study
precise uh I mean uh at the end we need
to go for wet lab experiments uh for
validation for validating our results so
how much do you think is the study
precise
yes so for validation I think that is
very much required
um once you have performed your
computational analytic analysis uh
you have to identify and probably
different uh studies like an independent
studies need to be performed in order to
make in true biological inference right
so in this particular stock I have not
shown any uh any experiment
or any kind of study that has that I
have performed but it is more of like a
general approach that I have taught
so how different kind of datas are there
how different tools are available how
you can actually perform the analysis
and so on
okay so I have not shown any particular
analysis or any study
hello smriti I hope that answers your
query
yes yes sir thank you very much thank
you
thank you
do we have any more questions
um so Khalid is asking is DNA barcoding
to identify an organism can be done by
this Digital Data method
and your question is
yes am I beautiful
yes am I Audible
yeah so I I see this uh question uh yeah
so DNA barcoding is exactly uh the same
um way actually so we again actually use
uh this store and identity of an
individual link to this barcoding uh but
this uh that the thing that I mentioned
is rather more of storing how you can
store this digital digitally generated
data which is primarily Imaging or any
kind of Text data that is being
generated nowadays on internet
um how you can actually precisely store
those informations in fact you can store
the identity of an individual also into
in the form of a DNA that barcoding is
actually to you identify
is a different thing it's not like the
problem statement that I am discussing
here so that here the problem statement
is how you store an image into a DNA
because if DNA can it's compact it's
precise is uh it's it's longevity is
more right so that that are the benefits
of storing and diffuse amount of Imaging
or any kind of digital data that is
being generated into into a DNA
but DNA barcoding to identify an
organism is different
foreign
[Music]
bioinformatics using ml Algos
looking to do research and
bioinformatics using ml Algos can you
suggest me the path how and where to
start is complete knowledge on biology
in Mississippi
um yeah my experience is that
um
you don't have to have a hardcore
biologist uh knowledge of the biology in
order to solve biological problems
uh in fact a lot of computer science
people they have who had joined this
field they have excelled and they have
really done very good work
uh
the only thing is that you need to have
some basic understanding of the biology
very fundamental course if you can take
like how what is DNA what is protein
what what what is the data like what is
genotype data what does that mean what
is uh uh
sequencing data Etc so you need to have
a very basic fundamental understanding
of the the biology and kind of data so
that that should that should be
sufficient I think you don't need to
have a very big um use Dash knowledge uh
in fact you if you find I think in that
also uh you need to find some
collaborators eventually in order to
make biological inference if you just
perform the analysis will not be able to
probably make the inference for that you
may approach some biologists I think
that will help you
okay is that I hope that answers will
very nourish
foreign
any other questions
just a short insight about drug design
development with help of bioinformatics
or AI so ankush is asking this
yeah I think that's very good question
so um
a lot of uh
actually work in Pharma Industries going
in this direction so um how we can
utilize AI or
for identifying first of all the drug
targets right so and then uh they use
drug repurposing is also something uh
people are doing so we have huge amounts
of
um uh you know the in interactions that
is happening between uh ligand and in
the Target it can be protein so you can
use AI you know to um
to actually
um
to identify or to predict what will be
the best
drug Target for given biological uh
Target so if you have a given protein
milk out of millions of these drug
molecules that are already available in
the market which of them will fit or
which will be more suitable for given
Target mymological Target so you can
perform this kind of predictions with
the help of AI because AI is more is
more useful in this kind of situations
similarly you have you you can identify
you can use AI actually to uh to
identify the biological targets itself
so if you perform
if you use the sequence data how you can
actually
for a given sequence data how you can
identify those biological targets with
the help of neural networks based
approach so there is a huge amount of
work that is going on and it is very
exciting field so if you plan to pursue
your
your future work in this direction I
would definitely encourage you
okay
okay so uh is there any more question I
see one more question in the chat box
um
it's questioned by saksha
how did you deploy ml algorithms in
large data sets like you showed in your
slides which algorithm should be used
for which data set training model
okay so
um
actually there are several uh places
where you can use uh you can you can
deploy ml algorithms uh in in like in
case of integration uh you can perform
uh some kind of uh
some kind of clustering and also some
kind of
predictions for example you can perform
machine learning you can use to predict
the uh the genes for example so if you
have a huge new genome uh what are the
how what are the regions which can be
coding or which can be possibly the
genes based on different other the model
that you have trained on different other
sequences right so in that way one
possibility is there where you can
simply apply ml algorithms for Gene
prediction
um and other so
application is in again in terms of
identifying let's say
the regulatory regions and like the
regions which control the transcription
or uh or regions which control the the
expression of the genes there also you
can use and you can also apply machine
learning for um
Motif identification which is again a
pattern of sequence right so these are
various various application where you
can find the ml algorithms
foreign
yes
all right so thank you so much
yes so you want to say something
yeah sorry yeah please
uh do we need to read last data set and
then decide
foreign
[Music]
sorry I couldn't get that
I said
can you elaborate I think I what he
meant is do we need to read about the
large data sets and then decide uh yeah
I mean it depends actually on the debt
kind of data set and the problem
statement that you have uh which ml
algorithm might be suitable what kind of
algorithm should be suitable whether
machine learning will be suitable or not
that is also first question that you
need to look
cool
okay
hi thank you so much sir uh for your
presentation and also answering the
questions and if you have any more
questions you can please post us on
marketing
mixlogic.com and we'll be glad to answer
your questions to your participants
and with that we would like to end
today's session but before I do that
I'll quickly take you through an
opportunity regarding the research
fellowship program so uh I can see that
many of you are interested in uh working
on a research project on multionics as
it is so as we received some questions
in the chat so I wanted to show you all
the research Fellowship opportunity here
is the link to the specific page you can
read about it if you are interested to
carry out your research project or
dissertation under mint guidance then
you can register yourself for this
specific program uh this program is for
either three months or six months where
in in the first few months you are
required to go through a coursework or a
training process I would rather say
where you go through all of these
Concepts get a good Hands-On
understanding with all the concepts
algorithm items pipelines and also
practice on the on the T by info server
various pipelines or multiomics data
analysis and then you start up with your
research project
now those who are interested you can
email us at marketing
logic.com so that we can share with you
more in science we are over time so I
won't be taking much time of everyone
present here but you can go through this
page for uh understanding what the
specific program is all about and also
we have listed some projects here by our
research fellows now this is a landing
page just with the information but if
you are interested to know more about
what type of projects students have
worked upon what type of research fields
or specialization tracks we are working
on you can visit the omics logic learn
portal and click on the projects tab to
look at the various research fellows
projects that are published on our
portal to get an Insight of what type of
project can you work on
so that was all that I wanted to discuss
very briefly and looking forward to meet
you in our next ionic session till then
have a nice weekend
and thank you so much Dr pankaj once
again bye